well guys I've been reading through the
over 1,500 questions that I was sent
through email wow that's a lot of
questions sorry it took a little longer
than I initially said that is the reason
why I took a little longer because yeah
that's a lot of questions I was able to
sift through them with some help and
I've picked out about 6065 questions
that were really good I'm gonna make
this a two-part video I'm gonna cover
about 30 questions in this video so
let's get right off the bat let's get
started with question number one Ben s
asks why do you think that less and less
people are going to the theaters these
days and what could a theater slash
Studios do to help sell more tickets
thanks Ben to be honest I think less and
less people are going to the theaters
for certain films you know because
certain films get like a ton of money
like you know all the the sequels of
successful franchises usually do really
well but I think people are just content
to watch movies in their home theaters
where they can just do whatever they
want if they want to go down and text
they can although that doesn't stop a
lot of patrons from texting and movie
theaters nowadays which leads me to my
other answer for this question I think a
lot of people are actually annoyed with
the movie going experience first off it
cost a lot of money now to go to the
movies and there's almost always some
annoying douchebag in the theater
texting or talking or munching or
turning rappers or something and I think
one way they could get more people into
the theater is to maybe perhaps enforce
more regulations about how people should
actually act while they're there shut up
and watch the movie please thank you
from him
Huggy I just want to know what film
would best describe your current love
life or maybe a film that sticks out in
your mind in your past love life thanks
thanks heem
you know I sat down with my girlfriend
and talked this over and you know me
just saying that just now actually
answers many questions I got and we
could not think of one because all
they're all cheesy and fake you know
what I mean and the ones that are
realistic are like kind of depressing so
the best one we could think of was Meet
the Parents yeah
if Acosta had a lot of good questions
but his best one that I thought was what
were some of the films you loved when
you were growing up like what were the
films that like shaped your youth and
for me I had a few the ones that I just
wore out the VHS tape were the Sandlot
the original Star Wars trilogy Princess
Bride Back to the Future toy story hook
these films growing up these were films
that I just watched endlessly and I
couldn't get enough of any of them and
they kind of shaped me as a film lover
as a kid I loved fun adventurous films
and that's one of the reasons why to
this day I just love films that they
feel like a ride but they took you on an
emotional journey and you know they were
fast paced and you felt like you you
experienced something fun and they left
you feeling good about life those are my
favorite types of movies those movies
that can impact you in really intense
ways and you know shape you as a person
but have a good time while you're doing
at the same time
Kenneth Rathbun asks what do you prefer
an engaging story or fascinating
characters interesting question because
in my opinion a story that may not be as
engaging could become more so if you
have fascinating characters I think
however that the characters might be the
most important part of a movie because
let's just say you got a movie that's
directed incredibly well it has really
good dialogue but you don't care about
the central guy or girl or any of the
people it's not gonna matter you have to
have characters that are likable
interesting you gotta want to watch see
what they're doing you know where these
people gonna go because no matter how
well a film is made if you don't like
him either people on screen or aren't at
least interested in them then it doesn't
really matter
Trevor Thornley asks hey Chris I was
wondering what is your favorite song by
Michael Jackson mine is beat it mine
would be probably Billie Jean that's the
song that kind of made me get into
Michael Jackson and everything and it
just actually so happens I'm currently
wearing a Michael Jackson shirt that is
an interesting coincidence that really
is a coincidence
I did not plan that Billie Jean is
probably my favorite yeah if you guys
don't know I do some dancing I'm a
dancer I have Dan
uh-huh in my life my feet have tapped
and I have danced roll the footage there
you go you saw it I did this video so
you guys get to know me more personally
and now you do so there you go thanks
for that question Trevor I'm just
kidding
Julian Martinez asks do you have any
tips on filmmaking if you guys don't
know my dream is really to direct
I love filmmaking I love watching other
people's films obviously I love
dissecting other people's films I love
trying to get any people's minds you
know the director or the writer or the
actors but I also love making my own
films and I've been making shorts ever
since I was like 13
like any random idea as I grew up it was
like guys get over here right now we got
to make this short film it's gonna be
awesome and you know there'd be a killer
outside with a knife or you know the
toys came alive at night do any random
little movie I would try to make it and
so I think really my best advice for you
would be to make what you like you know
don't try to make a film that you aren't
at least interested in in any way I mean
some directors will take a project that
scares them or challenges them that's
different you know when you're scared of
making a movie because you're afraid of
messing it up or something and you want
that challenge but don't direct a movie
that you have no interest in and if you
want to direct or write write about
something that truly interests you and
that you love and if you're forced into
some sort of filmmaking job that you
maybe don't like or love try to find
something about it you do and use that
to bolster you to making a better film
from Mario Arena that's an interesting
name I just want to say this question
has a spoiler for the Dark Knight Rises
so if you haven't seen the Dark Knight
Rises and you want to this is a spoiler
to that film did you have an issue with
Catwoman killing off Bane I thought it
diminished his role and he turned out to
be nothing more than Talia's henchman I
have no problem with him being Talia's
henchman I actually thought that
humanized him more as a villain and
was less of this you know you merely
adopted the dog I was born in it molded
by it I just made him seem more like a
person and I really like that aspect of
his character however my only issue with
the Dark Knight Rises still and I have
seen it four times is the way Bane died
I thought it was weak I think that the
only thing that should have been in that
movie is perhaps Batman you know looking
over at Bane and maybe having one last
little exchange or something as he died
you know not just blue there's Bane and
he's dead my only really issue with the
film some people have commented no Kris
you're a family for Dark Knight Rises
sorry I've seen it four times I'm gonna
be holds up I love it on the next
question from paulo escobar if you were
given a chance to write a Bond movie do
you think you will feel capable of doing
it I don't know if I want to write one
but I would definitely want a direct one
from writing to directing directing is
the thing that I have more passion for
thus I am better at it than I am writing
I would love to direct a Bond movie that
would be just incredible obviously
there'd be a lot of pressure and I'd be
very scared of making some horrible
mistake but I think I understand what
makes bond bond and I've watched all of
them and I've loved Bob my whole life
and I know the difference between a good
bond and a bad one I really would love
to be able to do that it'd be pretty
awesome and if I did I would definitely
go for the more mature route that the
most recent films have taken you know
where bond is truly a human and the
action seems real and a lot of people
ask this question also who would be a
good bond after Daniel Craig my vote is
Michael Fassbender he proved that he
could do fight scenes very well in
haywire he did it his own stunts and
everything and he was convincing and
he's also a fantastic actor and to me
he's just perfect for bond a lot of
people have been talking about idris
elba I think he's a great actor too but
I think Fassbender would be the better
choice from Mark Harrison he asks who
shaped your diverse taste in film your
sensibilities seem to be very mature for
your age I am 48 years old and I'm
astounded at how much I agree with your
reviews and taste thank you sir I think
it just has something to do with growing
up with older parents currently both my
parents are in their 60s and
so you know as I grew up my parents were
older and I sort of took on their older
isms that wasn't really very adult of me
to say I'm an old soul what can I say
and the way I was raised definitely lent
to that but my parents really are the
ones who showed me movies and I was a
kid they were the ones who were like
look sit down and watch Back to the
Future this is a good movie sit down and
watch Empire Strikes Back this is a good
movie and as I grew up I was able to
articulate my thoughts on film well
because of that I think so I owe lot to
my parents to be honest Michael King
asks what is your favorite anime of all
time
my favorite anime is Cowboy Bebop I have
a poster for it behind me that's
actually the movie great movie if you
haven't seen it the show is just
incredible
I mean don't look anything up about it
because it's very easy to get spoiled
that show is something that actually
changed my life to be honest the music
in that show by Yoko Kanno
I have I was listening to it today I'm
not even kidding I was listening to it
in the car today that music shaped add a
whole different side of me that start to
appreciate film noir even more because
of that show and jazz in general as
music because of that show it's
incredible just if you haven't gotten a
chance to see Cowboy Bebop the anime
it's only 26 episodes long check it out
please
it is my favorite television show ever
not just anime but TV show in general
second favorites Dragonball Z you guys
probably knew that andrew Hanratty Milan
Mullin apologize if I got that wrong
said to a very lengthy question here but
I'll get to the point he wants to know
how I feel about Shawshank Redemption
because that was a movie that impacted
him a lot I remember the first time I
saw the movie and it was before the
whole IMDB top 250 oh it's the
number-one film thing I just watched it
and you know I didn't have any that hype
in me I was younger and it was just like
wow this movie is incredible and it's
also kind of the movie that started the
idea of Morgan Freeman being the
greatest narrator alive that voice of
his off and the best scene in that movie
and oh my god if you haven't seen
Shawshank I'm about to spoil some
that scene where Morgan Freeman just
finally says to the the parole board how
he feels that is one of the best scenes
and best acted performances ever just
ever put to film that scene is
incredible and if you don't sit there
just staring at the screen and then get
this giant feeling of oh my god that was
incredible after watching that scene I
don't know man
check your pulse you know do you have
blood beating through your veins do you
have a heart that's pumping that blood
because that movie is a great film yes
definitely action Jackson five five five
asks do you have a demo reel of your
work that you can share and/or discuss
with the viewers yes I do have a little
bit of a demo reel it's actually
uploaded to a other channel that I have
called a Chris Stockman film it's where
I have a few of my short films if you
guys like to go watch some of them
because I know I got a lot of questions
about me uploading some of my short
films I do have a few of them on that
channel the link is in the description
below I have a demo reel on that channel
of some of my work as a director and a
few my short films are there go check
them out Spencer Nielson also asked me a
lot of questions but I want to pick out
what is the saddest movie you have ever
seen my friend the Elephant Man that
moot thinking about it right now I'm
getting misty-eyed that is the saddest
movie I have ever seen in my life
and it's a true story that's the other
thing it's a true story my god if you
haven't seen the Elephant Man it's
directed by David Lynch it's all in
black and white John Hurt plays an
immensely deformed man who is in
constant physical pain and torment from
people he was employed as a circus
sideshow freak Anthony Hopkins in one of
his best and most underrated
performances comes in and takes him out
of there and brings him to a hospital in
which he can hopefully be treated dear
Lord the performances in that movie are
mind-blowing one of the best scenes in
this movie without spoiling anything is
when Anthony Hopkins just loses it on
someone who is tormenting the Elephant
Man it is incredible
his performance in that movie and John
Hurt brings me to tears oh my god that
movie is so sad though it's so oh my god
the Elephant Man
Weston Davis sent me a few questions he
liked my drive analysis video and he
wants to know what do you think about
the walking dead how do you think the
new Star Wars saga will turn out and
what is your opinion on film school he
is apparently leaving for his Marine
Corps basic training this may and he's
considering to attend film school when
he gets out I hope that goes well for
you my friend I got a lot of questions
about the Walking Dead and Breaking Bad
and everything the truth is I actually
don't have cable TV right now I just
moved into my apartment and I don't
really have a lot of time for television
shows so I haven't got a chance to see
them trust me guys you don't even have
to tell me to watch the shows I've heard
it thousands of times I will eventually
watch them I will I like to watch shows
after they're released on the blu-ray
the seasons or DVD and I can just kind
of watch the whole show I enjoyed doing
it that way because I don't like the
whole cliffhanger thing constantly each
week don't worry I know I got it
Breaking Bad I got it Walking Dead we're
good how do I think the new Star Wars
saga will turn out and a lot of people
ask me about what do I think about
Disney buying Lucasfilm I'm incredibly
optimistic about it I really am because
Lucas it's got to give the guy props
because he created a great universe of
other films George Lucas is a guy who's
recognizing that his films should
continue on not necessarily with him
being hugely involved with them and
that's awesome I'm looking forward to
seeing where that goes I hope whoever
they get to direct this film is a fan of
Star Wars see that's really important
most of filmmakers of today were
inspired in some way by Star Wars and so
that's pretty cool the guy they already
got to write it Micheal arms for a Toy
Story three oscar-winning writer
fantastic let's go forth make it awesome
what do I think of film school I'm
actually considering going to film
school the tuition for the film school
up in Cleveland is rather expensive and
I'm saving for it and I might do that at
some point because I think I would love
to do film reviews like this for the
rest of my life but it's also kind of my
dream to direct and so I'd like to see
where that goes as well I'm thinking
about doing film school at some point so
Kay Kyser sent me the questions
are asked on inside the Actor's Studio
as James Lipton always likes to say the
great Bernard DeVos questionnaire what
is your favorite word
my favorite word hmm I was gonna say yes
as my favorite word but then I realized
what if I was like doctor do I have AIDS
and he was like yes then that wouldn't
be my favorite word I don't know
actually
my least favorite word boy that's he
there I can think up some things because
some people say stuff you know they say
words and I hate them you know what word
I can't stand swag I hate that word it's
so stupid
if anyone's like I got swag I'm like
you're an idiot shut up I really don't
like that word Slade hawk has a few
questions for me who is your favorite
you reviewer do you like Jeremy Jones I
do like Jeremy Jones we're buddies
however my favorite dudes are the
schmoes I just had a chance to actually
meet Marc Ellis he came to Cleveland for
one of his stand-up routines he was
great really awesome guy had a drink
with him after the show for like an hour
we just chatted about movies and stuff
really cool guy those guys are my
favorite youtuber viewers for sure
number two are you a gamer if yes can we
expect to see a video game reviews from
you I am actually a gamer don't tell
anyone
whoops I told people I'm looking back
here my systems I got a ps3 a Wii and
n64 and an NES the original Nintendo
system and my wii is technically a
Gamecube as well so right now I'm
playing through Dead Space 2 I'd just be
dead space great games next on my list
is the Uncharted games can't wait to
play those so many people have told me
to play those any yes I'm gonna make an
announcement in this video I am planning
on starting to review video games in the
future I would love to do that I've been
a gamer my whole life I know a lot about
games and I would love to talk with you
guys about games and I'm going to do
that in the future Slade also asks will
these questions really be answered
yes from Angelo acquire apologize but
got that wrong who's your favorite
Dragon Ball Z supervillain Frieza there
you go
Aaron Lee Lozano asked a very heartfelt
question he talked to me about how he
has aspirations to be a film director
and a lot of the things that he goes
through and some of the issues he has
which I will not divulge to you because
they were personal and very heartfelt
but he would like to know how I became a
film critic and an independent film
director and what was my process in
doing that I still don't consider myself
like the film critic guy I just I love
talking about movies and I did it for
fun for a long time and I'm still doing
it for fun and you guys enjoy it and I
thank you for that even when I post a
review for The Hobbit saying it's just
all right and you guys freak out
whatever I still love it I'm kidding I
really am kidding I don't care no I just
I love talking about movies and I love
that you guys love to talk about movies
with me and because of that Aaron I kind
of started doing it for fun and just
posting my reviews and talking about
movies and I kept doing it and I was
consistent and reliable and I try not to
miss any movies I do every once in a
while but I try hard not to and I try to
get my reviews up as quick as I possibly
can as for being a director I'm not
technically one you know I'm not being
employed as a director it's just I can't
turn that part of my brain off when I go
outside it's like I see stuff and I
think about it in a frame I'm like what
would this look like sixteen by nine
widescreen that's how my mind works I
can't turn it off and I would love to do
that professionally one day it's a goal
and a dream of mine for sure and I
really hope that you are able to meet
your goals as well my friend crazy guy
100 asks ever since I've been subscribed
I've wondered where and how do you get
the posters on your wall
dude that might actually be the most
asked question I've ever got and I can't
believe it because I just bought him on
amazon.com it's very simple you go on
amazon.com you look 11 by 17 that's what
most of those are type in the movie you
want
they'll send it to you that's simple
some of them I got at the movie theater
you know they have a big table where
they just kind of put him there and here
you go take him oh yeah take down take
down baby
like dark night movie theater you know
like the more obscure ones like die hard
with a vengeance I obviously order from
Amazon and the Empire Strikes Back same
where the Lost Ark same cowboy bebop
movie same order them from the internet
they're cheap and pretty cool to have
Riley Van Pelt says hey Chris I heard
you're tall how tall are you
you heard correctly I am 6-4 yep I'm a
tall Beast
about as tall as Liam Neeson Conan
O'Brien I was always the taller kid in
class I was always on the third step
when we took the class picture you know
been barred get sent me some very
interesting questions do you watch
foreign films not counting anime if yes
to the question before why don't you do
reviews of these well the honest truth
of the matter is yes I will watch a
foreign film I even have a few of them
if they are considered to be pretty good
you know if I'm not just gonna like
watch some random French movie that
someone said sucked you know what I mean
like why would I do that if I hear that
a really good foreign film is coming out
I will try to see it here's the issue
and to answer your second question about
why I don't review some of these I do
actually have some foreign film reviews
on there I reviewed the skin I live in
last year which was really good great
film Spanish film I have reviewed
foreign films before the problem is in
Cleveland you don't get too many of
those coming out so that's why it's just
a matter of what do I get screenings for
what can I actually go to what comes to
Cleveland you know cuz most of these
things stay in New York and LA you don't
get it a lot of chance to see them and
by the time they're out on DVD and
blu-ray that you know I mean the time
has passed and that's kind of the
unfortunate problem I have with that
kind of thing
Sohail Iqbal from England apologize if I
butchered that send me a very inspiring
email about the fact that he watched my
why I love movies video and he said that
it really inspired him to think about
his life actually he says he put on the
Inception soundtrack and just kind of
thought about his life and decided he
wanted to make some changes and
first off that's incredible
I can't even process that thank you
that's amazing and I'm glad that that
worked out for you I really am but his
question eventually is is there anything
that has inspired you to get up and
change the way you think or live or feel
perhaps a movie a song or even a person
you know just to start off my parents I
mean my parents really inspired me in a
lot of different ways in my life I've
met a lot of people you know throughout
my life friends I have that have really
inspired me as well I mentioned this in
my wild love movies video the first time
I ever watched where I was like jeez you
know movies are an art form with signs
it's not like the best movie ever made
or anything but it's just I remember
that's the first time I was watching a
movie where I went people make movies I
want to do that you know what I mean so
thanks very much for your heartfelt
question Alonso Brown thanks me in this
very much for the videos you are welcome
sir and he asked if you could be in a
fictional character like Batman James
Bond Gandalf who would you choose to be
and why see I would like to be a
fictional character from a movie for
like maybe a couple days if I knew
nothing bad was gonna happen
because you know maybe I would be cool
to be Gandalf but you know maybe freakin
Saruman is gonna attack me or something
you know maybe it would be cool to be
Batman
but maybe Bane is gonna break my back
today I don't want to deal with that
however it would be freaking awesome to
be Batman for a day and just go out and
just lay waste to criminals just to be
Batman and go out there just hold a guy
and be like swear to me I mean how great
would that be
Pierre Luiz asks what is your workout I
think John Flixter said that you work
out I do I basically I have a membership
to Planet Fitness and I go there and I
lived weights I lift heavy things no sir
I do bicep curls I do whatever this is
called a lot um I get on the elliptical
for a long time I basically try to
workout as many muscles in my body as I
can while steering fat I don't have like
a particular style of work
hangout I just know that I want to get
into better shape and it's funny you
know if you guys actually want to do
this go back to like one of my videos in
like April or something yeah my
wanderlust review just go find my
wanderlust review and then compare my
face then to what I look like now I've
actually lost probably 1015 pounds and
gained some muscle mass it's been
working out working out has been working
out
Coulson dourif char so sorry if I messed
that up
he sent me also a very inspiring email
about his passions as a filmmaker slash
actor and he would like some advice on
filmmaking first off just thank you for
considering me a credible source for
advice that's awesome you know because
that just it makes me feel special thank
you as I said earlier I really think
it's important to tell stories that you
are attached to in some way or affect
you emotionally stories that you love or
give a performance that you feel could
affect other people in that way I think
the best type of filmmaking and the best
type of filmmakers are the people who
are trying to infuse whatever they love
whatever they have loved our passion for
into other people and those people are
in my opinion the best type of actors or
filmmakers those people who do inspire
that's the best kind of advice that I
can give to anyone who is trying to be
an actor or a director or a writer or
anything just tell stories that you love
to try to make other people feel that
same love and passion that you have
d-dog asks how do you feel about people
who don't share your opinion about
certain movies do you brand them as
somebody with no taste or do you tell
yourself that you're happy that they
enjoyed it do you put them down or do
you move on and smile at the fact that
somebody enjoyed a movie you bashed
example Twilight piranha etc when you do
movie reviews and it gets to the point
where so many people are commenting on
your videos and you hear so many
different opinions no opinion surprises
me at all anymore I've had people tell
me that the Dark Knight is the worst
comic book film ever made which you know
okay so you don't like the movie but
seriously have you seen Superman for the
quest for peace just you know what I
mean I've heard everything so no
I do not feel that the bashing is
necessary for someone who has a
different opinion I've been surprised by
opinions I've been shocked by opinions
but whatever if you have your opinion on
a movie great one of the things I talked
about recently was my Hobbit review
where a lot of people were like upset
that I didn't love the film and I just
had some problems with it and you know I
thought it was disappointing but still
an alright movie and a lot of people
didn't like that okay so you'd you know
you didn't like my opinion on the movie
I guess I'm gonna go die now it doesn't
matter really you know what I mean it's
just I'm telling you guys how I feel and
if you felt differently great I'm glad
you enjoyed whatever movie that was or
if you disliked a film that I loved okay
that's fine
you know whatever go on happy and skip
through lily fields it doesn't matter
Kristin Johnson or DJ HAMB HAMB
for one one who comments on my videos
quite often
thank you ma'am asked if it were real
and you could obtain a golden ticket
like passport similar to the one and
last action hero that would allow you to
travel to any movie you desired which
movie would you travel to first and why
you know what would be pretty awesome if
I could go into the matrix and have the
knowledge that I'm in the matrix and
have all the abilities of say neo you
know you can fly around have all these
amazing kung fu abilities be like hey
you know it'd be kind of cool if I could
like build a skyscraper okay let me just
load this floppy disk that allows you to
do that be cool to be in the matrix you
know to be able to load any desire you
want it just load it there it is and you
can also create any fantasy world that
you want it like the woman in the red
dress you know I was like yeah from
Butte a misen this is a incredibly good
question when you go to an advanced
screening for a film that has not had
any reviews yet therefore having no
expectations do you ever fear being the
only critic to either like or dislike
the movie when you post your review that
thought has entered my mind yes and I've
never allowed it to actually you know
change my opinion
but I can't lie about the fact that I've
seen movies and been like man am I the
only one who feels this way and then
once reviews start trickling in I'm like
okay so I'm not for instance I saw The
Last Airbender before any reviews were
out no one was talking about this movie
in a bad or negative way everyone was
pumped for it
everyone was excited and I saw the movie
and as you know I left just shocked out
of my mind
and I went dear lord please tell me this
is not me and then other people started
seeing it other people started seeing it
I was like wow that's great for instance
and this also links to my previous
question about opinions and do I let
them affect me when I posted my review
for The Last Airbender
it had like freaking 500 dislikes or
something like it was crazy it was one
of my first reviews to ever get a lot of
hints and everything and it was really
what I got like 2,000 subscribers in a
week or something it was really awesome
and all the comments were like you suck
this room is gonna be awesome blah blah
blah and then the movie came out and the
dislike stopped and the likes just grew
and grew and I kind of liked that I like
the idea of going to movies at advanced
screenings knowing that you know I don't
have to think about what other people
are thinking right now you know what I
mean and it's pretty cool for a movie
reviewer to be able to do that because
as you guys know I like to have as less
expectations as I possibly can
alright so that concludes part 1 of my
Q&A thank you very much for your
wonderful questions I will have part two
up soon I appreciate you guys questions
there's a lot of really good ones some
really funny wants to and some really
inspiring ones thank you so much I was
really surprised there was only a couple
weird questions in the entire lot it was
really amazing I was like I'm gonna get
some weird ones I was actually hoping to
create a little segment where I just
reviewed the the weird questions but I
really didn't get that many I got a lot
of inspiring awesome ones so thank you
guys very much I'll be back soon with
part two and as always if you like this
and you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]